Steve at the end of the last unit we
were talking about the importance of the
redeemer imagery for second Isaiah and I
was saying that the Redeemer language
ultimately is family language and it
seems to be making the point that the
community of the second Isaiah thinks of
itself as family and all subsequent
interpreters within that tradition all
the way down through and beyond the
christian interpretations of this
material are also to think of themselves
somehow as family beginning in chapter
49 though we've got even more of these
family references some of which use the
redemption language and others don't how
does this expansion of the notion of
family work in this particular part of
the second Isaiah yeah it really is
fascinating the this language of
redeemer go away all in Hebrew it's very
powerful here you've got this these
people in Babylonian exile suffering
horribly worried that perhaps the
Davidic King ship has been decimated the
covenants been broken what do they do
the type of marriage that a husband
redeemer say has to a wife that he would
be obligated to come and rescue her from
whatever debt or slavery she got bound
up in - that's a ongoing permanent
eternal commitment of the husband to the
to the wife it's bound up in these
family ties which are really not
supposed to sever so to picture God as a
committed husband redeemer is to speak
of the type of covenant that God had
with Abraham that's eternal it's
perpetual God's commitment isn't
dependent on Israel's obedience lack
thereof her sentence it's perpetual
which is a very different view than some
other biblical views the book of
Deuteronomy and also the Book of
Jeremiah do talk about a divorce that
takes place between God and Israel and
the relationship cannot be
reestablished after that for legal and
cultic reasons and that becomes an
argument for the absolute severing of
the relationship between israel and god
the second Isaiah seems to be arguing
here exactly the opposite thing
well this notion I think is very helpful
spiritually the idea that God is
committed to us and that our Redemption
by God is on its from God's side and
it's through grace and we don't have to
earn it we don't have to deserve it we
can completely mess up and fall on our
faces and God is still committed like a
husband loving a wife there's that
intimate connection um I think it's it's
rich spiritually however the other side
of this when we when we get into this
Redemption language is that this family
is highly troubled the the wife of God
the metaphorical lover of God is Zion
daughter Zion
she's been decimated by the Babylonian
destruction of Jerusalem in 586 and her
suffering is is incomparable in our
section in Chapter 51
let's say verse 18 God admits there's no
one to guide this woman among all the
children she's born there's no one to
take her by the hand who's who can even
more in for a person who's been so
devastated by destruction famine and
sword it's healing I think just for God
to come out and to admit that she has
suffered way beyond anything anyone
could ever deserve and I think it's
spiritually interesting for us when God
admits that some of the tragedy in our
human experience is way beyond anything
that even God can put up with and is in
God's mind extremely interesting but
there is this family language there's
God as the Redeemer redeeming husband
Zion as as the wife and also her
children but the denial that an actual
divorce has taken place and raises the
question again of whether or not the
redemption of Israel the redemption of
the community the redemption
Zion is going to take place through the
use of human agents at all we've spent a
lot of time working with this idea of
human agents that seem to pop up all
over second Isaiah and do you think it
is simply the case that at the end of
the day it this all has to be some kind
of a divine act or are people finally
involved in this and what do you make of
this repetition still of the servant
language in these chapters does the
servant really have a role is there any
sense in which the community or the city
are responsible for their own Redemption
or does this all have to be an outright
divine act what is second Isaiah's view
on all this I think this is something
really worth pondering you've got this
family God Zion where does the this
mysterious figure of the servant that
we've alluded to where does the servant
figure fit in and is Israel in any way
involved in its own Redemption I think I
mean for me you can feel free to
disagree Bob but I think it's
interesting that that the wife of God
daughter Zion bears these miracle
children if you look in chapter 49
around verses eighteen nineteen twenty
twenty-one Sian puts on beauty like a
like a bride and all of a sudden her
children are gathering to her the
children of whom you were bereaved are
now so many that the place is too
crowded for them sort of this miracle
blossoming of the remnant on Mount Zion
who where did they come from it's a
miracle there's no way just like Abraham
and Sarah had a miracle children there's
no way it could happen without God doing
it but are they in some way related to
the servant are they the folks who have
taken up this new lifestyle of reverence
of humility and frailty and are running
with it
is that the way that human beings
participate in this Redemption by
emulating the servant by being children
of the servant so this also may hark
back to the beginning of these images of
calling the community to return all the
way back in chapter 40 where again the
notion of too much suffering on the part
of Jerusalem was also raised there all
these themes now seem to be coming back
in this language about the restoration
of the family as well as some major
confusion about roles and who does what
which seems to be characteristic of the
second Isaiah material and the answer to
who the agent of redemption actually is
one wonders whether or not this might be
both of these things well I do think I
think many times in Christianity there
is an emphasis on the individual
spiritual relationship with God but
second Isaiah will not let you keep it
just at that the whole notion of a
redeemer as you say involves the
creation of an entire community that is
involved in this lifestyle the
spirituality this virtue of reverence
before before this awesome towering god
of other nests this inscrutable deity
it's not an individual phenomenon it's a
new lifestyle that should spread and
infect the world and really change
politics and economics and hard hard
reality does does the serve and have
children are their progeny I think we'll
see in the next section that that he
does when we when we get to chapter 53
verse 10 God is putting him through this
and if he's willing to bear up
faithfully he will see offspring you'll
see progeny you'll see seed so at least
by the end of this
corpus of second Isaiah you beginning to
get these promises of a new breed of
growth Messianic seed or posterity
that's just emulating the servant
lifestyle and spreading it like peanut
butter so the relationships between the
individual servant and the communal
responsibility of the people as servant
are related to each other in some way
that is never quite clear but as we
proceed in this material it seems to be
the case that the individual Redeemer
the servant is going to be a model of
some sort for the community and this
sounds an awful lot like the way that
people begin to understand Jesus in the
Gospels that Jesus is in some way a
model for how the community is supposed
to say Jesus died on the cross
accomplished salvation
thank goodness we're dying not according
to the Gospel of Mark and some other
places where it's pretty clear that
Jesus is simply the example of what the
community is responsible
it's the germ of something starting with
energy and it is Spanish and that the
community somehow cannot get off the
hook you cannot have Redemption
individually done to you right
you really have to participate in it in
a corporate way and you have some
responsibility to bring Redemption to
the remainder of the community I think
that's gonna be offensive I mean a lot
of Christians want Jesus to be
completely different and unique
accomplishing Redemption
we can't be Jesus no but certainly the
second Isaiah and I would argue also the
Gospel of Mark and elsewhere where the
community of disciples has a imitative
role to play in this process of
salvation and you got it all the way
again back in chapter 40 you got the
community benefiting from God's leading
them back to Zion but then they become
the agents of God's Redemption once they
get back there and they precede them to
redeem all of the cities of Judah
so in the next unit we're going to look
at again it more carefully at these
individual figures and particularly what
is probably the most unusual of the
servant poems